yeah my son's birthday party on Saturday
really at the sky Zone the trampoline
place it's fun my son played the place
is dangerous
oh yeah oh yeah it is Oh trampolines are
dangerous well if they don't have them
well protected it like we rented out an
area right so just for his friends for
his bday but there was a area in the mat
where I was like dude there's a huge
hole here cop a kid could easily slide
through they go oh [ __ ] sorry I had to
move us why come on let's figure out
right there that's all sit food
krandalls how some of the dads to get
way too serious like is their release
and playtime day party sort of jumping
around hurting kids so that was fun
I rented a spider-man who apparently
spider-man decided to stop fighting
crime for a short while yeah but himself
go OK and he's a fan of the devil's
dandruff you told me that all that about
a 47 year old spider-man at least yeah
makes many bad decisions in his life
it's a tough one yeah I told you when I
had the highlights at man my son had
Pirates of the Caribbean I'm the guy I
was speaking in the terrible accent like
this he was from England but it was Ted
I was like you need to get a I was
judging the [ __ ] out of every tear every
one of their performances can you put a
little effort into it here's that to me
I find it depressing I don't want to
rent to my girl rent them ionized like
this what you get we paid $75 for
spider-man for a seven hours correct of
course that correct so that's my face so
until you picture this because I must be
happy in that in that outfit I was
trying to feed my son and he would not
[ __ ] well Pizza you got a pizza
because you want being big and healthy
like smarter and get your beats I want
dude calm okay face how do get my son
like dude cuz I and I told aspiring like
dude you has a 10 I need you out of 4
for the kid you're scaring everybody my
son's I can eat then you go oh no
problem dude
there you go [ __ ] cucumbers lettuce
tomatoes mushrooms how do you want to be
super-hearing like inspiron didn't talk
like that bro I don't know what that is
that's not Peter Parker yeah you said
the next round out he's getting crap
doing that he crashed [ __ ] oh yeah
we'll see what happens only last 45
minutes well he snuffed enough of it to
last a solid hour ish and then it crash
hard
masks half-up sweating profuseiy go you
want to jumpiest nah man I don't jump
well we're paying free we need you like
you look like firemen so just kind of
stick and jump on the wall yes no it's
one thing I don't do I don't jump man
all right all right
we've had enough of spider and you can
go home yeah that's fine
did Ramona lecture yeah tip him a little
extra you got a tip got a tip well was
good he can't get a teacher he came to
he came to Hollywood expect him to be
[ __ ] Bradley Cooper Fame is all about
intimacy now it used to be about
distance yeah right yeah like and who
gets it better than Will Smith hmm Will
Smith bombs four movies in a row but
he's so [ __ ] smart he goes what the
[ __ ] is happening I'm Will Smith yeah
whatever I do wins and this is not
winning what's going on and he realizes
oh [ __ ] fame is not about hiding out in
the hills and then coming out and do a
movie two two times here one time of
year fame now is about hey how you doing
hey I'm here okay this is my family hey
this is everything that's going on we do
I'm normal wouldn't like you guys
whatever one of your fans say when they
meet you right they know you they know
you and they do what was what was famed
ten years ago for 15 years 20 years ago
it was nothing there's no Creed why is
Johnny Depp a bozo curious he's a boy he
has no friends you didn't come down to
the real work so go what the [ __ ] are
you doing I why do you have so many
necklaces you don't have a friend who
can tell them hey bro enough with the
[ __ ] look look at that - go to the top
left one and you could see the full
front row of Brian Collins first
[Laughter]
you're on the side
if you hit that arrow I mean doing
what's going on oh dude he's just he's
just he's out and like he's not he's not
one of us he's not a human he's from
another planet healthy he just has no
idea what's up on and when someone goes
dude your some of your movies are
terrible no one's told him that I now he
thinks he's jackspehn well my weekend
was tough you're in Vancouver right my
weekend was amazing in Vancouver we sold
out when my folk theater I see Will
Sasso was on there as well sure was he
was hilarious he played well David Greco
which was a bit of bad comic dude he had
me die
at one point he had pages and he was
like one fat huh he was reading the joke
and he as a performer this [ __ ]
is you don't get battle area you don't
get better you don't get better I was
watching him with in awe he's just fun
assassins
oh so [ __ ] hot and they went crazy
little man you know it's Vancouver oh
they went crazily gyah he's like the
wrong burgundy of ink I had a blood
walking legend in and out but I had a
plow just one show Friday or this one
show
Thursday's economy festival yeah comedy
fest so then did you fly back on Friday
go back home I know you're in town I
thought you for something that though
you ground the whole weekend I was in
town did you yeah you you were super
quiet because I thought you my feelings
were a little hurt weird I think I'm
Vancouver cause I work because Friday
night I was at two shows I had one with
Rogan that one usually when I don't hear
from you I go very quiet I know I know I
thought you were in Vancouver in the
whole time I came around with the kids
the whole weekend that's just the wife
cuz the wife is in Atlanta doing what I
don't know just doing some stuff she's
busy with dude what Lana huh yeah she's
dead land Wow I know you're gonna say
her no giant attractive black men with
huge pipe in Atlanta it's a chocolate it
here's not that it's a chocolate say it
it's not Vegas for black creates a
chocolate city and it works the
chocolate Mecca now in Atlanta I don't
want to get it I don't want to get into
any of it right now but I don't either
but if you've gun to my head yeah she
was doing but
to that because she listens and she gets
mad dude whoa why are you doing the wall
rest you're doing the walrus Washington
oh that was the walrus no no no washing
her hair no all right so let's let's
move on to that Charlemagne I don't know
he's walking the best smart guy so sharp
and so honest like I've seen him take
Kanye to task and yeah he's he's
brilliant them in and I remember that
one guy who came in and wasn't really
mad at him that rapper who was like you
know oh yeah Birdman Birdman yeah he's a
he's like a producer yeah yeah yeah but
he's such a he's such a
I was called how do you how did you guys
meet at empty yeah we met at MTV and it
was just like I think before Charlemagne
was the guy at MTV I was the guy there
right like they would have me hosting
the Spring Breaks and hosting the
European Music Awards and [ __ ] like so I
bet you guys didn't [ __ ] any girls
[Laughter]
stupidly I had a girl at that time it
was bad Charlamagne yeah he's had a wife
for like 18 years but he used to cheat
yeah I know now he's he's part of like
the faithful guy got more of a few faith
he brags about now being faithful to so
there's at that time you're the man that
Charlemagne came in Charlemagne then
Charlemont comes in he is he like takes
over New York radio like what he did
with the with power 105 one is really
only like Stern did that back in the day
did he did he get a start with one day
we got a star Wendy yeah he did that and
he did stuff with Wendy and he had been
working in Philadelphia I think and he's
just got fired from every place 41 40 41
what I think what works with with both
use especially for you is you guys went
through that TV route and if you said
the same stuff because I'll show you
guys show and scene with Brian and Brian
might get fired but if some of the stuff
that we say so outlandish yeah if you
put that on MTV Showtime or Network they
like do we can't have it oh yeah it's
cost us a lot of money but then again we
don't need it no you don't need it but
it is good because we have this other
thing and thank God because then you're
allowed to say it but like yeah man I
mean we've had things that cost us you
know I mean Nicki Minaj owes me $100
well you know the other thing that I
want to sock you in the face right I
want it I want it Wow
because my wife she'll lately sure man
brother yeah sure it looks pretty cool
like how you do this with your jaw where
are you going now
what is that peekaboo peekaboo that's
what you hear what I'm punching it I'm
not kidding do did you hear a boy Dustin
Poirier you got a fight who's he
fighting see you're not friends with him
brought you when he's my he's my dad I
come off with your feet next to me right
now
hey Dustin no yes oh yeah who's he
fighting ah there it is
I know he's fighting yep Tony nope
I know I know he's fighting whoo-hoo
what did you say yeah I'm willing for
you
it's fighting khabib definitely not for
her sake you know that what's it what do
you want to know yep want to know one
more shoe is he fighting at live 5 at 55
55 yeah pounders ah he will be fighting
100% dogs running damn again close but
no do you want one more try I'd like one
more try out more try it's not it's in
Barbosa definitely not nobody make
anything no I would make no sense it has
to be a guy who's who's up there top of
the food chain if I put my my thinking
cap on I'm gonna know right away now we
have various guys we've got Paul Felder
well hey big fights bro yeah bitty
fights big water also has one lung and
still in the hospital he's just one long
lung burst
oh no why old news keep guessing man
hold on dude am I is an intriguing fire
dude if you say Chuck Liddell I'm gonna
rip your [ __ ] nose off
hoist Gracie is it gonna be is it gonna
be is it gonna be a is it intriguing am
I gonna be excited is data 5000 entry
given all right all right hold on hold
on hold on why am I having trouble why
am I having it's max Holloway max always
coming up it's a home run [ __ ] I knew
that you already beat max Holloway to
only a big name fight this is great for
our boy this is jet it doesn't pour -
sorry max always
I love max I'll do two great boxers
great spiders damn it do you want to
punch you in the dick today I don't know
what it is why don't you [ __ ] ball
your fist up and suck me right in my own
[ __ ] three-piece set come on it's
come on let me squeeze it up I'll get it
all hernia and you [ __ ] socket and
watch my face not change out same guys
like God
dad let's say you'll hear me do as I'm
herniating my nuts Bulldog your nuts
I would Bulldog my nuts right now if
there are only guys in this room where
the camera might pull off you know I
would do it but no I don't mind anybody
can see my balls when you see my back
Riblet I pull myself up like a champ
like a champ thirty times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift